dame kate your task doing the vaccine
task force was to source a vaccine
scale up capacity
build capability in vaccine development
then make for the provision of
international distribution and then
strengthen the uk's capability for
resilience for future pandemics which
actually sounds exhausting just reading
it all out
there's so much to talk about about that
and also about
future proof and against pandemics but
if we kick off with what you did in the
vaccine task force what was the single
biggest lesson you learned in that whole
process
i mean the single biggest lesson was
probably getting the right team together
and having a clear mandate and
empowering the team to actually do the
work that we needed to do because
everything was in a rush because every
day we took more people were going to
die so
the first thing we did was to actually
put together the experts from industry
together with the experts from
government and agree this is the
strategy and this is how we're going to
do it and because there was so much
uncertainty what we did is put in place
a very uh focused um set of meetings
three times a week so that we at least
had a framework with which to actually
start
communicating what we were doing and
talking about progress so getting that
team together
uh getting a diverse team together
actually so we had plenty of women
who brought real depth of skills
alongside
the men we had in the team
in terms of learning diversity of skills
people thinking backgrounds
made for a really effective team and
without the team this couldn't have
happened now it was a success it's
transformed everyone's lives that
the vaccine rollout worked and the
vaccine was found
but when you were contemplating this at
the beginning
did it occur to you that you were most
likely going to fail i knew it was most
likely to fail
and there were so many reasons why it
was likely to fail the first thing was
that we had no vaccine against any human
coronavirus so we had no template or
playbook to follow the second thing was
that vaccines historically take five to
ten years to develop the quickest was at
four years and that was done for uh 50
years ago
and we didn't know anything about this
new virus so we had so many reasons to
be skeptical that this was possible and
to be able to
go from sequence to start vaccinating
people in a year
which is what we did was not what we
expected to do at the beginning because
we knew that most vaccines fail you're
obviously a very successful person was
there a moment you thought this is
kamikaze i'm setting myself up for
failure how did it come about that you
took the helm
the reason i was
asked was because patrick valance um had
set up an expert advisory group to
advise the government on the procurement
and identification and procurement of
vaccines
and he then invited me to join that
advisory group and my job for the last
30 years has been to develop novel uh
drugs uh to treat unmet diseases and so
when patrick then asked me to join the
expert group i
asked him why since i don't know
anything about vaccines um and he said
but you understand the small company uh
landscape and it's that innovation
landscape which is actually where the
bulk of the vaccines have come from so
he brought you in because he knew you
from industry
but then the prime minister personally
called you up correct and asked you to
do it everything is done by text so you
get a text saying can you speak so i
first got a text from matt saying could
i speak i then spoke to him and he then
said the prime minister had asked him to
ask me to do it i then said i want 24
hours to think about it and 24 hours
later i went back with a list of
conditions on the the basis of which i
would do it and having established that
then the pm called me and that was to
seal the deal then really that was to
basically accept the conditions which
was six months that i reported to
the pm that i would have a quick
decision-making process
um that i could hire my own team to be
able to get on and do it i mean did you
have this phone you thought i am
i'm going to fact this is awful i've
been asked to do something i've got to
do because it's the pm's asking me in
the middle of a pandemic
and i don't know if i can do it so
absolutely i had that entire imposter
syndrome you know i can't do it and i'm
not the right person um and that was
because i'm not a vaccine expert and
they did so but while i do therapeutics
so
what i'm very familiar with is how do
you develop new drugs and in patients
but those are for patients
who have a disease putting something
into people who are healthy volunteers
is just a little bit different prophetic
vaccines and so when i was called
i hooked on the vaccine as being this is
what they're wanting me for but actually
they're not they want what they want is
someone who can do basically what
venture capitalists do which is put
teams together build plans uh figure out
milestone based
events which you which are key to
actually the success of the development
of of the
whether it's the therapeutic or a
vaccine
and so there's lots of the style of how
venture capitalists work is what was
needed here and the venture capitalist
mindset
and then whitehall
they're kind of different culturally
different very different things
you presumably met quite a lot of
resistance that's my first question then
my second question on this is that
is the venture capitalist mindset only
applicable in
the public sector when it's an emergency
situation
so two questions on the did i meet
resistance not really is the answer so i
had
absolute support and cooperation from
the pm and actually if you've got that
top level
leadership it is incredibly helpful
right and i established upfront that we
were going to be putting
money at risk without knowing if any of
these vaccines would work so it's what
the what the um whitehall calls no
regrets funding right and so we've
established the principle that if we
wanted a vaccine we were going to have
to put money up front there was a lot of
scrutiny around you the fact that you
were married to a treasury minister you
know you know there's all these sorts of
this charge about being part of the
chamocracy if you like and there you are
doing this incredibly hard job uh
for and not being paid to do it did you
ever have moments when that happened
thinking i've put myself i've been asked
to do i've stepped up to do it and now
i'm being publicly criticized you didn't
really have a right of reply did you
just sometimes say why have i bothered
like why the hell am i doing it did it
annoy you of course it annoyed me um
the challenge is um this all happened um
just only a few weeks before i was due
to finish and by then we'd put it all in
place had all that happened early on
um it might well we might well have
ended up in a different place but it
might have walked you mean
oh it just may not we never would have
achieved what we achieved the advice i
got um was incredibly clear which is
take your ego out of this focus on what
you're doing and and move on because
this will all possibly did it and it did
yeah of course it did
it's very bizarre when you when you're
not used to being in that world to have
a whole lot of people say a whole lot of
lies about you and you can't respond
i mean it's really bizarre
lily allen has a great song and so i
used to go uh running we're in the dark
with a head torch on listening to lily
allen and it was great and i'm not going
to say the name of the song in public
yeah
i watched your romance lecture you gave
it in oxford in 2021
and you spoke about how your father your
late father lord bingham
had been honored given that lecture
19 was it 19 years before you gave yours
or 18 it was one of the other
and and you talked about
you you spoke about how he talked about
um the vulnerability of personal freedom
in times of crisis
and then i saw you you paused um
and you you needed to kind of collect
yourself and use
when you spoke about your dad what was
what was in your mind at that moment um
i just i caught mum's eye who was
sitting in the front row and you know
i'd practiced it and i'd said it so many
times so it wasn't as if i was saying it
for the first time but then seeing mum
sitting there that's what absolutely uh
triggered me so i don't have to say just
stop and it was actually i mean it was
actually a lovely moment you know
it wasn't absolutely but it was
unexpected for me but well incredible
that you followed your dad as well and
one mother question about him as i said
he was widely regarded as the greatest
lawyer of his generation one of the most
seniors justices in
the land um how did he influence you
your dad uh
not to go into the law
so i went and did
i mean i was very keen uh i think to
carve my own path and that's why i ended
up in science so no nobody else in my
family does science uh nobody else does
sort of small business e innovation risk
that sort of thing so i think i'm just a
you know and maverick
right let's quickly get on to future
pandora it's covered is it over what we
know is we are we had delta um variant
that was really very serious last year
we're now in the middle of omicron
this could continue to
evolve um an outcome you know new
variants could out compete the question
is will it ultimately end up as a
seasonal flu type disease and we hope
that is where it will end up so that
there's sufficient levels of immunity
that we won't have this well kate i mean
patrick valance when i've gone to the
press conferences he has talked about
this transition from pandemic to endemic
or epidemic endemic endemic
where it does become like the seasonal
flu but you you say it's still not clear
i don't think it's quite there yet right
um and
and so to the extent i mean the stat we
heard this morning was ten percent of
of children in the uk have coveted right
now so that is still a vast level of
viral transmission and presence in the
in in the country so we just don't know
yet what the remaining drift and
mutations could be
is the government ready to scale up in
the way it did before
should another virus come along
that really threatens
the the public well a lot of the scale
up has been done so part of what our job
was in 2020 was to put those plans in
place so we
um
basically took the existing ecosystem
for vaccine manufacturing and scale up
and nine different sites around the
country we have now uh funded to scale
up into much more significant
capability so we've got a lot more
capability here now you talked about
having someone in government that's
responsible for this yes i mean i think
we should be treating it like we treat
defence because you know we're much more
likely to get a another serious pandemic
than we are to be invaded by somebody
yes but really serious not just a
cabinet minister yeah absolutely okay
and it needs to be somebody ideally um
uh that comes in i think that needs to
have that private sector experience if
you suggested that's the pm yeah of
course and what did he say oh they you
know they'll take all those suggestions
well ultimately
transpires i don't know
do you think that we have finally killed
the stereotype that science is a boy's
subject i mean there's a lot of very
very punchy women who were absolutely
instrumental in in the whole initial
covid response um no i don't and i think
it's partly because um we don't
uh teach our kids in school as to what
the what you can do in science so people
i still think think of scientists as
being you know men in white coats well
actually it's not that if you think
about what we're dealing with in
technology whether it's phone apps or
cyber security or how do you deal with
climate change and as soon as you start
saying well all of those underpin
underpin by scientific understanding
actually that's what's going to get
people excited because these new you
know younger people now they absolutely
want to help um save the world do you
think it's a coincidence that the people
heavily involved in
this vaccine were women
i think women are very good at problem
solving and just getting on with it as
you did well look thank you so much
thanks kate for talking to me i
appreciate it pleasure thanks for having
me